>>Sam Dutton: Hi, everyone.
I think we're ready to begin if you would
like to take a seat.
Glad to see everyone here.
Yeah, we're here to talk about the Chrome
Development Tools today.
If you are here for something else, I think
you should stay because it will be a really
good session.
My name is Sam Dutton, I'm a developer advocate
for Google Chrome.
I'm based in London.
>>Pavel Feldman: And I'm Pavel Feldman, software
engineer working at Google Chrome.
>>Sam Dutton: And yeah, we're going to show
you some great new features in Tools and hopefully
some stuff that can make your life easier
as a developer.
You know, 2012 has just been an incredible
year on the Web.
I was looking back at the session that Pavel
did with -- Paul Irish is in the house somewhere
-- last year, and it amazes me how much the
Chrome Tools have evolved in that time, how
much the Web has changed in that time.
It just seems like the normal thing now for
you guys to be building these apps that are
incredibly complex and really pushing the
limits of development on the clients' side.
And I think that one thing I've found is that
in a context, you know, a really great text
editor just isn't always enough.
And with that in mind I think that's where
the Chrome Dev Tools come in.
So what are we going to talk about today?
Well, we're going to run through some tools
that we hope will boost your productivity.
And we'll also be looking in some detail at
using the tools to do mobile Web developments.
We'll also be looking at this idea of responsiveness.
You know, what is it?
How do we measure it and how do we deal with
it in a scientific way rather than with guesswork?
And you know, in a balance to that, also looking
at memory and making sure that we stay on
top of that.
And all through this we'll be looking at a
whole bunch of new features in the Tools.
But first, we just wanted to say, you know,
I really big tip of the hat to all the people
who have contributed to the Tools in the last
year with bug reports, feature requests and,
you know, by committing code.
We've got a list here of some stuff, just
touching the surface of stuff that's been
put into the Tools in the last year just from
user requests and user codes, you know, fantastic
contributions, really good stuff.
Just to pick on one of these things, this
business of caching.
Caching is a good thing, but it can be a real
pain for developers.
Particularly when you're dealing with situations
where assets are being loaded dynamically
after the onload event and in those situations
a hard reload or whatever just isn't enough.
So we have two new features in the tools.
From the network panel you can right-click
and clear the browser cache or you can even
just turn off caching from the settings page.
So yeah, great stuff from our users, and we're
really grateful for that.
So with that in mind, we've got this roomful
of great developers, we thought we would take
this opportunity to try and get from you guys
some ideas about what you would like right
here, right now, to see next in the Tools.
You know, what challenges are you facing now?
What would you like to see?
Pavel?
>>Pavel Feldman: Right, guys, that's your
only opportunity, unique opportunity, to request
something, and even without filing a bug I
will be implementing it for you.
So please shout out what you want from the
devtools and we'll type it in and we'll make
sure it's not lost.
>>Sam Dutton: Right here, right now, shout
it out.
>>> [Inaudible - No Mic].
>>Sam Dutton: Okay, next, please.
>>Sam Dutton: Thanks very much.
One here.
>>> [Inaudible - No Mic]
>>Sam Dutton: And while on this side?
>>> [Inaudible - No Mic].
>>Sam Dutton: That we already have.
>>Pavel Feldman: Let me put it in.
I will be happy to file the bug and close
it.
>>Sam Dutton: Okay.
Down the front.
>>> Storing edited CSS.
>>> [Inaudible - No Mic].
>>Sam Dutton: Okay.
And who else down in the front?
>>> [Inaudible - No Mic].
>>Sam Dutton: Here.
>>Sam Dutton: Yes?
>>> [Inaudible - No Mic].
>>Sam Dutton: Maybe two more.
>>Sam Dutton: Like by the system in other
words, like for San Serif or whatever.
Behind you there.
>>> Bigger text in the developer tools.
>>Sam Dutton: Ah, we can help you with that.
Bigger text.
>>Pavel Feldman: Bigger text.
>>Sam Dutton: And right out the back.
>>> Support for CSS preprocessors.
>>Sam Dutton: Yes.
Good, good.
That's fantastic.
>>Pavel Feldman: Okay.
That's a good list.
I'm happy to say that at least half of it
is already implemented.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sam Dutton: That's great.
We'll take that.
>>Pavel Feldman: So I'm making sure it is
not lost.
I'll be filing those by myself and probably
will be implementing some of those personally.
>>Sam Dutton: And I'll be following him around
with a whip.
[ Applause ]
>>Sam Dutton: So you know, like one of the
things -- another thing we've noticed over
the last 12 months or so is that people are
using the tools now more for actually writing
code, for building interfaces, not just for
debugging.
And with that in mind, when the devtools team
have built in some great features for working
in the tools in that way, and I was thinking
about just how to demonstrate it, how it increases
productivity, and I was thinking about the
devtools team themselves, like the devtools
team build the devtools to build the devtools.
And good developers are really productive,
so who better to ask about productivity than
Pavel Feldman.
It would be a good opportunity to give Pavel
Feldman a chance to give us a master class,
show us how he works.
>>Pavel Feldman: Now I feel flattered.
Okay.
Before we jump into the demos, let me say
a few words about the productivity.
What do we expect from the Tools for productivity?
And for me it is getting into the source into
where I need to fast.
And being a part of the screen or an action
or a process, I like to jump instantly into
the source code that is responsible for this
action.
And vice versa, while looking at the source
I want to know what it is responsible for,
how do I get the part of the screen that it
paints?
While in the source code I am interested in
changing it and more importantly I'm interesting
in seeing an immediate feedback.
And for those of you who have seen the Bret
Victor's "Inventing on Principle" talk, if
you haven't, please make sure you check it
out.
That's an image from Bret's slides.
So the main principle Bret is talking about
is the instant feedback.
And as he goes through his demos it is clear
that the instant feedback not only increases
your productivity, makes you do things faster,
but it also boosts your creativity, because
when things are reflected fast, when you have
an instant feedback, you start experimenting.
You go through the states that you have otherwise
not visit.
Now that you have changed the source code
and you've seen the feedback, the essential
part of the tool is to persist it.
So let me show you how these map into the
devtools features.
I just started Chrome Canary, and it is a
version of Chrome that is being updated on
your machine daily.
It is built from the tip of the tree sources
from WebKit and Chrome and contains all the
features that are implemented by this date,
including the devtools ones.
So if you are a Web developer and you would
like to make sure that everything works perfectly
on the next version of Chrome or if you'd
like to use the tip of the tree devtools,
please use the Canary and please provide us
with your feedback.
But more importantly, Canary can run side
by side with your Chrome browser, so you no
longer need to choose whether you want to
be on the Dev channel or Beta channel or Stable
to test for the changes, just have those two
installed and that will be very convenient.
Oh, I have no connectivity.
Sorry.
It just plugged out.
So I'm navigating to the WebKit.org.
And WebKit is the project where most of the
Chrome devtools source code belongs.
We develop devtools fronted upstream.
Let me load it once again.
Okay.
Let's go to the backup plan.
We have a backup plan, don't we?
Yeah, we do.
[ Laughter ]
>>Pavel Feldman: So that's the WebKit.
And I'm going to do a lot of demos on the
devtools, and we're going to hack devtools
today, and after this session you will be
able to contribute your source code into the
devtools yourself.
Now, I'm going to debug this page, but before
I -- I'm not going to open the devtools using
the command option I, I'll do it different
then.
I'm using remote debugging to start inspecting
my page.
And as you can see, remote debugging works
as a regular devtools.
You can see the devtools is opened as a Web
page.
I can do that because developer tools uses
clients server architecture where browser
acts as a server and a front end acts as a
client.
So the devtools that you have in your browser
is in fact a Web app read in HTML, JavaScript,
CSS, and it's talking to the backup using
Web Sockets.
Did you know that?
Okay, good.
Now, it's -- is it okay?
Now it's time to debug.
And as you can see, I open the devtools doc
to the right and let me [Indiscernible].
Here we go.
So what we are going to do here today is we
are going to hack on the devtools itself because
I'm a devtools engineer.
I want to show you what I'm doing everyday.
So that's regular old stuff.
This is your Web page to the left.
In my case it's devtools.
And that's your devtools to the right.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sam Dutton: Pavel's life is so meta.
>>Pavel Feldman: So we get a bit of inception
here, so don't get confused.
Okay.
Now, I've been working lately on the timeline
features.
And as I was editing the timeline features,
I noticed the timeline does not really look
like the rest of the Chrome.
We implemented it in WebKit, we were using
these colorful gradients, 3D loops, we don't
really do that in Chrome, so I needed to fix
it.
And when you were working in a UI like that,
you need to go back and forth between the
page and your source code until what you see
satisfies you.
Let's try to recreate this experience right
now.
I'm recording a couple of timelines in here,
and if you can see those gray zebra bars in
the central part of the timeline, let me make
them a bit more conscious for you.
To do that I'm using the inspect element tool
to locate the actual code responsible for
the zebra bar.
And in here I can play around with its colors
using the color meter.
Let me increase it or maybe play with the
color.
And I can do it dynamically in here.
I have a range of values I am choosing.
And that's really a simplistic example of
what Bret was talking about, because as I
go through these ranges I was just going to
bump the conscious a bit, but now I like the
different color I can accept it.
Let's check if the sources were updated.
And they were updated, so that's my new color.
Nice.
But I think we have a bug because in the top
part of this grid you can see the overview.
It also has the zebra bar, but it was not
updated.
We are probably doing a bad job, we don't
use constants here or the style we're using
is different.
Let me do the same thing with the top area.
So I inspect it.
Whoa.
That's not CSS, so it's not going to work
like that.
We all love CSS because it's declarative language.
You change a value and you get an instant
feedback, everything updated live.
Canvas is just JavaScript, imperative language.
Painting on a canvas, you can't go into the
source code and change things dynamically,
or can you?
For that let us try and find out what source
code is responsible for this painting.
Remember we want to go from the screen into
the source code.
For that I'm using command alt F, and I'm
just going to search for canvas.
And it searches through all my source project,
and through the entire project.
As you can see, we have a number of components
that are using canvas, but I think the timeline
overview pane is the one that I need, so I'm
jumping to it.
And while we are here let me say a few words
about the new sources panel.
So the sources panel is the one where you
are dealing with your source code.
You are going to view it there, you are going
to modify it there, you are going to save
it there, you're going to jump on to the source
code from your URL, so we need more real estate
for that.
For that we now have collapsible debugger
sidebars and expandable tree view with all
of your sources.
And remember Web scales you need a lot of
space for the list of your files.
But do you know what?
You don't really need it at all times on your
screen because you can hit command O and jump
to any file instantly.
As I type, the list narrows down and I can
jump into a particular file or even a particular
line number.
[ Applause ]
>>Pavel Feldman: Now, remember what were we
doing?
We were looking for canvas, right?
So let us search for canvas.
There are a lot of occurrences.
Does not work.
Or let us go through -- oh, the methods.
I'm pressing command shift O and I get a list
of all the functions in this file.
And the same very thing will work for your
selectors in the style sheet.
And as I type, the list narrows down and I
can jump to a particular function, but unfortunately
there is no clue on the canvas and the zebra
stripes, so let's go on.
But I think I have an idea.
I think this code uses the same color of the
CSS.
Do you remember the color?
What was the color there?
>>> [Inaudible - No Mic].
>>Pavel Feldman: 50% gray?
Any more options?
So let's see if you're right.
I'm pressing control -- I'm using the context
menu, control click in my case, and I'm looking
for local modifications, and I can see all
the files that were edited within this editing
session.
[ Applause ]
>>Pavel Feldman: And let me search for the
old color definition.
Here you go.
Let me grab the new one.
Okay.
>>> [Inaudible - No Mic].
>>Pavel Feldman: I am using context menu,
local modifications.
We'll go there in a bit.
Now, I'm replacing the code with a new value.
And unlike in Bret's demos, unfortunately
the screen is not updated, but the reason
is that we are not using requestAnimationFrame
to paint our canvas painting.
We updated upon resize or any event that is
being painted in this overview.
Let us try and keep those modifications while
resizing.
Here you go.
So what happened under the hood is the V8
driven live edit, step in place, so when I
save the file the actual machine code generated
for that source file, for that JavaScript,
was patched at runtime.
And any subsequent execution of that code
was using the new code.
Now, let's see if the local modifications,
it's a context menu in here or in the scripts
navigator to the left, captured our changes.
And of course, they are here.
Now, let's see if we actually like them.
I'm going to go ahead and apply original content
for top and bottom areas.
And, no, I like the new way more, okay.
Applying the revision content.
I'm keeping the changes again.
So as you can see, you can experiment with
the revisions of your edited source files,
be it JavaScript or CSS.
Now that we have edited all, we need to save
it.
And for that we are going to use context menu
and save as.
Here you can bind your source file to the
file system location and all of the subsequent
saves are going to write to that location.
Or you can do something more interesting.
You can actually install an extension, Chrome
extension, from the Web store.
I'm using a (indiscernible) device devtools
have to save for that.
And my extension is installed and configured.
So that it mapped the particular -- the URL
into the particular location of my file system.
Once I mapped it, everything else just happens
automatically.
Let's go and -- go ahead and see if the changes
are in place.
And here they are.
So the changes were indeed persistent in the
file system and I was not doing anything for
that.
[ Applause ]
>>Pavel Feldman: Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So now that's the -- that's the productivity
story.
We can jump into the source file, we can change
it to immediate feedback persistent, but it's
really easy to provide such an instant feedback
when you are working on a desktop, because
both your page and the devtools are on the
same screen in the same box.
Wouldn't it be great if the same experience
could exist while you are working for mobile.
Sam?
>>Sam Dutton: Well, yeah, the good news is
that the devtools are available now for mobile.
The devtools team have done a huge amount
of work over the last year to implement remote
debugging in WebKit, and we are really pleased
to see this code being used across the industry
now.
Because there is no better way to -- to get
a really good impression of what your Web
app is actually like out in the world than
to do remote debugging via USB on a real device
that's getting real 2G, 3G, whatever real
connectivity.
And, yeah, we would like to show you that
right now, actually.
>>Pavel Feldman: Let me check it now.
Internet connection?
>>Sam Dutton: We've got internet?
>>Pavel Feldman: Yeah.
>>Sam Dutton: That's good.
Okay.
So it's really easy to set up.
We go to the device.
You need to log me in here.
>>Pavel Feldman: Okay, sure.
I won't be showing it to you.
Sorry.
>>Sam Dutton: So on the device in Chrome,
you need to go to settings.
>>Pavel Feldman: There you go.
>>Sam Dutton: And from there you can go to
--
>>Pavel Feldman: Wait, let me do it for you.
>>Sam Dutton: Yeah.
Okay.
Get the right one so I can see what I'm doing.
In settings, you go to developer tools, then
make sure that enable Web USB debugging is
enabled.
That's all you need to do on Chrome on the
device.
And -- and now we have installed the Android
SDK on the desktop and then run port forwarding,
ADB port forwarding so that now we can look
at Port 9223, which will show all of the pages
that are open on the mobile device.
We'll just open up YouTube now.
And you can see what's going on there.
>>Pavel Feldman: Yeah.
>>Sam Dutton: There we go.
>>Pavel Feldman: That's opened up.
>>Sam Dutton: Right, so we have got devtools
there for the mobile device there.
>>Pavel Feldman: Right.
[ Applause ]
>>Pavel Feldman: Thank you.
So now let's see how it works.
Of course, you can do simple stuff.
So as I hover here, you get areas in the screen
of data.
[ Applause ]
>>Pavel Feldman: All right.
Or you can go vice versa, and Sam could you
click on an image here.
Yeah.
And here it is.
The image that Sam has been clicking.
You can see it big in here.
But that's simple, right, you can modify DOM
here or play with the CSS, but that's all
simple, you can do it with the other tools
as well.
But as Sam was saying, you could do some interesting
things with the mobile handset.
For example, let's go to the network.
While I'm on the network panel, I'm pressing
command R, to reload the target page.
It usually reloads the target page for the
devtools, but in this case it reloaded the
YouTube.
What you can see in here is the precise network
information.
That with the DNS connecting, sending, waiting
numbers, for your cellular network, for 2G,
3G, taken from the network stack, from this
various device, so that's the actual information
in milliseconds came from this native network
stack.
Of course you have all of the other information,
all of the previews, responses, cookies, everything
that is available in the devtools, but again
it's the mobile.
Let's say you want something more complex.
You want to see how the cell phone performs
on your tasks.
So I'm reloading the YouTube again, and timeline
shows me not only network events but also
the style recalculation or JavaScript execution
that happened on this very CPU architecture,
different from my box, at this very CPU this
handset is running.
Or even more fun stuff.
Let's do some breakpoints in here.
I'm going to set a breakpoint.
Oh, I have one on the mouse click.
Can you click it again?
Here you go.
You stopped on the breakpoint in the cell
phone, all of the regular devtools features
are available here, so you can prettyprint,
I can step through my execution and everything
just works.
So that's all of the devtools features, full-fledged
developer tools running against the mobile.
[ Applause ]
>>Pavel Feldman: Take it from there.
>>Sam Dutton: That's fantastic stuff.
So the -- I guess looking at the other side
of it, one thing that we've learned after
kinda 12 months of remote debugging is that
of course in lots of situations, it's most
the best thing to do to begin by doing as
much as you can on the desktop tools.
But, of course, for that what you would need
is really accurate emulation tools.
And the devtools team has been working really
hard on putting a lot of those features into
those tools, which we will show some of that
now, I think.
>>Pavel Feldman: Sure.
>>Sam Dutton: We'll go over here.
So we go over to YouTube.
Let's open it over here.
There we go.
So we've got -- yeah, we've got the desktop
version there, and the remote version over
there.
Now, I would like to go to the settings in
the developer tools.
And if I go into there, and -- and let's -- let's
go to the user agent panel there.
You can see the tabs now in the settings.
And if I click on user agent, now what's -- it's
a Galaxy Nexus --
>>Pavel Feldman: It's a Galaxy Nexus, yes.
Does anyone have one?
>>Sam Dutton: Yes, so I will select that now.
And -- and that's -- let's refresh that.
You can see we've got a really accurate representation
of what it actually looks like on the mobile
device.
And let's just -- in fact, this little button
here, I don't know if you can see that, it
kind of swaps from portrait to landscape mode
pretty handy.
So if I click that and just zoom out again,
you can see now again we have got a really
accurate representation.
One thing that we've got here, you know, it's
not kind of faking it.
You will be able to use Media Queries for
this and it will work, so, yeah, really handy
stuff.
I will turn that off.
[ Applause ]
>>Sam Dutton: And obviously another crucial
feature when you are trying to build for mobile
devices is touch.
And if we go to this example, it's -- it gives
us, you know, the ability to see how touch
works.
The only problem being --
>>Pavel Feldman: Override.
You --
>>Sam Dutton: Sorry, I left the override on
there.
>>Pavel Feldman: Yeah.
>>Sam Dutton: Okay, just refresh that.
And, yeah, so what you can do here is use
touchevents, but, you know, it doesn't work
obviously.
What we have in the tools is the ability now
to emulate touchevents and you can set breakpoints
and so on, there we have it.
I'm using touch there on the desktop device.
So, yeah, really handy tool.
>>Pavel Feldman: So you were just dragging
your mouse and it was emulating the touch.
>>Sam Dutton: Right, yeah, that's good stuff.
So, um, I would like to just kind of I don't
know shift focus a little bit now.
We've talked a lot about the parts of the
tools that make your life easier as a developer.
Also, you know, thinking about the users of
your apps.
What's in it for them?
And, you know, particularly in this world
we have now where users really come to expect
from Web apps these, you know, these new features
that really push the limits of the CPU and
GPU and memory and so on and, you know, in
that context, in particular, how do we -- how
do we measure responsiveness?
You know, this idea like what is it, how do
we measure it?
And luckily, we have some tools for that.
I was thinking in particular, you know, a
website you may have seen called HTML5rocks.
It's got a really nice interface, really great
content.
But we've noticed some, you know, just slight
stuttering, it's hard to see here.
But some slight stuttering with scrolling
on the page and, you know, the thing was coming
at that problem -- you know, there are a million
things it could have been.
And what I wanted to know from Pavel is how
do we approach that problem where you really
kind of have no idea where to start.
So, yeah, I thought maybe you could give us
hints there.
>>Pavel Feldman: Yeah, of course.
So you start with the timeline when you don't
know what's happening in the page, especially
if you have performance issues in the page,
you start with the timeline.
So let us record a timeline in here.
I will do devtools to get a bit more real
estate in here.
And in the timeline, I am pressing record
the record button and I go to the page, and
I scroll it a bit, and then I go back and
turn off the recording.
So what I can see here, let me zoom into a
window here.
What I can see here is a lot of events are
happening within the browser.
And timeline not only shows us the JavaScript
events, it shows all of the native events,
styles, painting, everything that happens
in the browser.
While hovering over these elements, you can
see what is actually taking time.
Yellow is scripting, blue is loading, we didn't
have any and green is painting.
So this picture gives you a very good understanding
of what's slow.
>>Sam Dutton: Yeah.
That's good.
I mean, the only problem is, you know, I remember
when I first saw this timeline thing I thought,
wow, that's lot of information.
But it's kind of useless, you know.
It's like where do we go from there?
It doesn't really give me a picture of what's
happening each time there's a slowness --
>>Pavel Feldman: I give up.
So we've gotten exactly this feedback from
you and we thought we need something better.
And with this version of Chrome we are introducing
a new frame mode of the timeline.
Let me zoom into a couple of frames.
So with these frame mode in the timeline,
we are defining a new term, a frame.
And the frame is the amount of time that the
browser needs to update the screen.
It includes everything.
JavaScript processing, recalculation of the
styles, painting, everything is happening
within the single frame and then your user
sees the picture.
You can see the same nice color coding in
here.
Green is paint, purple is layout, styles and
the yellow is scripting.
But more importantly, we set a baseline to
you.
And this baseline is 60-hertz.
60 frames per second.
That's what browser expects from you.
You need to generate 60 frames each second.
It gives you only 16 milliseconds per frame.
That's the same vsync signal that we've been
talking about on the keynote.
Now, if we look at this very page, we can
see that the frame was taking, in fact, 45
milliseconds.
And it is above the baseline of the 60 frames
per second.
This solid line in the middle.
So it's not JavaScript in your case.
It's not styles.
It's the paint.
You must be painting something very beautiful.
>>Sam Dutton: Yeah, yeah, no I know.
[Laughter].
>>Sam Dutton: What I know is the culprit is
-- yeah, some there's some heavy duty CSS
in there, a lot of gradients.
>>Pavel Feldman: Oh, I know!
[Laughter]
>>Sam Dutton: Aesthetic.
Nice background image.
>>Pavel Feldman: I know it's nice, but it's
slow.
I removed all of them, and the page still
has that background.
What's wrong?
Okay.
Let's inspect.
Oh, are there are more.
[Laughter]
>>Pavel Feldman: And those are the same.
You are using all over again the same gradients.
>>Sam Dutton: Twice is good.
[Laughter].
>>Pavel Feldman: Okay.
Maybe it was making it slow.
Okay.
Anyways, now that I've disabled everything
and you can't really tell the difference,
can you?
Let me go back to the timeline and start recording.
And let me scroll here a bit.
Go back and stop my timeline.
[Laughter].
[ Applause ]
>>Pavel Feldman: There's nice 16 milliseconds
frame, thank you.
>>Sam Dutton: Yeah, okay, well done.
>>> [ Inaudible - no mic ]
>>Pavel Feldman: Okay.
Let's take it to the Q and A.
Thank you.
>>Sam Dutton: Yeah, and if you want to learn
more about that stuff, after us there's the
jank buster session.
It will go into more detail.
>>Pavel Feldman: Right.
So that was smooth animations.
Wrapping up, please measure performance of
your animations and scrolling.
Now we have a good baseline, 16 milliseconds,
you will know for sure, (indiscernible) smooth
has now a value, it's 60.
Use this time wisely.
Think as game developers.
Game developers don't have much time for a
frame.
Tools will help you narrowing down the problem,
whether it's paint or JavaScript.
After you know the paint events and you need
to bisect those, regress, find where the culprit
is.
For the JavaScript we have better tools.
We will point you to the very line of the
source code that is updating the layout or
recalculating styles.
So you will know what is wrong.
And as Sam mentioned, in this very room, right
after ours, there is going to be an extended
session on the frames mode for the timeline
and the GPU team from Chrome is going to drive
it.
So make sure you don't miss it.
>>Sam Dutton: Yeah, great stuff.
Of course, Pavel was kind of cheating there.
You know, you can always just delete stuff
to make a web app work faster.
>>Pavel Feldman: You can?
[Laughter].
>>Sam Dutton: That's true.
But, you know, I mean we all know that these
situations, as much as you optimize everything,
all your code, you get to a point sometimes
where you've got some code that is just inherently
CPU intensive, long running.
And, you know, I was thinking about how to
use the devtools to deal with that.
And I was thinking of -- you know, the prettyprint
function itself.
What I have noticed with that is that, you
know, it's obviously doing a lot of work but
it doesn't seem to freeze up the interface,
so I have asked Pavel about how that works.
>>Pavel Feldman: Right, so it does use more
than 16 milliseconds of time.
We are using WebWorkers to move the work off
into the other thread.
>>Sam Dutton: Okay, Yeah.
I mean, I always feel like I should use WebWorkers.
>>Pavel Feldman: Do you use WebWorkers?
Not much, okay.
>>Sam Dutton: But I always sort of shy away
from it, because I feel like they are hard
to debug, you know, like where do you start?
>>Pavel Feldman: Oh, is it?
[Laughter].
>>Pavel Feldman: Let's try that.
As I mentioned we will be focusing on the
WebWorkers, so let me go back to the page
where we were debugging devtools, for the
devtools.
We will be interested in the source code.
Do we have any?
Well, let's reload.
Let's get some.
Yeah, we've got some files.
Okay.
So here is the source code.
As you probably know, when you press this
little button, it gets prettyprinted, really
nice.
And as I mentioned, it happens in the worker.
So let's try going ahead and debug it.
I'm going to the debugger sidebar, under the
workers tab I choose to pause on start.
So what it should do, when the worker is created
for your page, it should stop it before the
very first statement this worker executes.
And we should be able to debug it.
Let's try it out.
Okay.
Now that we have three windows with the devtools
on the screen, I feel I must go over them
again.
So the one to the left, is your Web page.
It's just me, I have the devtools, sorry.
One to the right is the devtools.
And the one in the middle is the devtools
for the worker.
[Laughter].
>>Sam Dutton: Got it.
>>Pavel Feldman: Yeah, is that okay?
Right.
So I can step through the execution here and
I can see that I'm debugging the worker.
The worker is stopped.
But he can scroll the page.
So the page is not blocked by the worker.
So this is not the fake worker emulation using
iFrames, this is the real stuff, native workers
being debugged.
Now, of course you can use all of the debugging
functions in here or you can go and collect
CPU profiles or take heap snapshots, do the
timeline for the worker or use console.
This devtools window is working in the context
of your worker.
And if you type window in here, there is no
window and there's no document.
Who are you?
[Laughter]
>>Pavel Feldman: It is dedicated worker context.
So this is in fact the worker object.
Now, we support debugging workers, the dedicated
workers and the shared workers.
And the way to start debugging shared workers
is to visit Chrome Inspect.
That's where all of the inspectable properties
of Chrome are represented, be it page or an
extension or a background page, application,
shared worker, everything you can start from
here.
You click inspect and you are brought to the
right window.
So that's the WebWorker story.
[ Applause ]
>>Sam Dutton: I may even use them now.
We talked a lot about memory, but of course,
there's always some kind of tradeoff with
performance.
Well, or is there?
We did some testing of Google Web apps, and
you can see on the graph here, the yellow
line at the top there represents overtime
memory consumption, and the blue with a high
level variance represents the measure of the
projection of latency.
One thing we're finding with Web apps, I think
this is a common experience now, people are
using Web Apps for much longer than they used
to.
We have users of Google Apps like running
them for days.
So you need to be aware of that.
What we learned was obviously that there were
memory leaks and that we could fix, and the
most common source of that was problematic
-- in fact, it was problematic usage of event
listeners.
>>Pavel Feldman: Okay.
So I think we have some tools for that.
>>Sam Dutton: Yeah, indeed.
>>Pavel Feldman: And we're going to explore
a simple example of the memory leak, and --
>>Sam Dutton: That's a lovely website.
>>Pavel Feldman: Yeah.
So I'm going to the source, and let us see
the source code.
So what it does is every time I click "say
hello", it creates an element.
Hello, there.
And it adds it to the result.
But then in a second it just removed them
all.
But they all are still here in this array.
Let's see how the tool handles that memory
leak case.
But now let's imagine we don't know it all
and we start from scratch.
Can you forget everything that I've just said?
I'm going to start recording the timeline,
and a number of clicks in here, and let me
undock the timeline.
Oops.
And we are going to look at the memory view
for it, and let me face the window.
What you can see here is the heap graph.
That's the memory your app is consuming at
the top, so it's a bit more than a megabyte.
Then there is a regular timeline, and then
there is the memory counters, DOM counters,
and event list counters represented in here.
You can see that the number of DOM notes increased
from 18 to 24 as I was clicking, and the document
is still alone, and there are two new event
listeners in here.
If I click on the step, I will see that there
is an event associated with that.
So every time it grows, there is some event
in here, and indeed the link, we can hover
over and jump to the line that was creating
that object, of course, but more importantly
we now know what user action is causing the
leak.
Now that we know what is the problem, we'll
find the actual location of that object.
And for that we turn to the profiler, and
in the profiler, I'm going to -- let me go
back to the page.
I'm going to take a heap snapshot.
Let me say hello a few more times and take
another heap snapshot, and let's see what
it is all about.
So the heap snapshot is in fact the snapshot
of the JavaScript heap of running application.
And the summary view that I'm looking at is
the summary for the heap where all the objects
are grouped by their type.
For example, those are API functions and those
are date objects.
Those are Chrome events.
So everything is grouped in here.
For each of the objects I can see -- for each
of the group I can see the object count, shadow
size and the retain size, so its own size
and the size of the tree it is holding.
Now, if I go to the second snapshot, that
was taken after my actions that are supposed
to leak, I can compare it to the first one.
[ APPLAUSE ]
And in the comparison mode, I can see that
there are 7 new objects.
And if I hover over these objects, you get
this hover card that you got used to while
debugging, and if I select this object, it
will show me the retaining trees for this
object.
Those are the guys that reference my object.
And those are the real cause of the memory
leak.
In this case, I have an array.
And in its 13th slot there is this paragraph
element, and, you know these dollar zero that
refers the currently selected element in the
elements panel, it also works in here.
So from this panel you can jump into the source
-- into the console, into the running object
and explore it there.
Let's see what is holding this array?
It's a window.
It's a global object.
And the property name on it is "holding",
so if I do dollar zero, that's my window,
and if I do dollar zero holding, that's the
array that was holding the paragraph element.
So to recap that, if you don't know where
your memory leak is or where is the unbonded
cache that you're using, you should go to
the time line, then you perform your actions
and look at the spikes in the DOM node counters.
There is also garbage collection button that
you can press in the timeline to collect the
garbage that should bring everything back
to normal.
If it doesn't, this means you have a leak.
Now that you have tracked down the user scenario
that is responsible for your leak, start using
the heap profiler.
You take a heap snapshot, then you do your
action, you take another snapshot and then
you compare the two.
And once you've seen the leak objects, the
objects that should not be there, look for
suspicious classes that you own the code,
you know it.
Then track the retainers in the bottom part
of the screen to track them to the global
objects and you will see the exact path that
is leaking memory.
There are more complicated techniques for
finding memory leaks that are more efficient
such as three snapshot technology where you
take three snapshots, then you look at the
third, and filter out everything that has
been allocated between one and two, or actually
show everything that has been allocated between
one and two, but it's a different technique.
It's more complex.
It's beyond this session, but we are here
at the Chrome booth, so if you have questions
there, make sure you come and ask them there.
Okay.
>>Sam Dutton: Thanks very much, Pavel, really
useful tools for dealing with memory as well
as performance.
We don't have much more time, but I just wanted
to mention a couple of more features that
have come into the tools now, really useful
stuff, particularly in relation to clientside
story.
>>Pavel Feldman: It's not the end.
>>Sam Dutton: Have a look at the features
for index DB and App Cache.
Have you seen the web components?
We have great tools for shadow DOM inspection,
just go to the elements panel and drill down
into an element and you will see the shadow
DOM compliance.
It's great stuff.
My favorite thing of all, Pavel wouldn't let
me demonstrate is source maps.
These are really easy to work with, you know,
you use a tool like closure to minify your
code, at the same time you make a source map
file, you put a link to the source map file
in the minified code, and that's it.
When you use that code in the devtools, you'll
see the human readable version seamlessly
in place.
It makes life much easier.
>>Pavel Feldman: Come on.
Come on.
How can you love a feature like that?
Here is my favorite one.
Here is the WebKit, right?
Let us go back there.
No, let's do Google.
So in the Dev Tools, right, I'm a developer,
and where is everything in here?
Okay.
And there's Google, and sometimes I am ambitious
and I kind of think, okay, let me change things
here, and it will be a Google search, supersearch
-- it didn't apply.
Why?
They are fooling me.
Come on.
Do it again.
>>Sam Dutton: That's weird.
>>Pavel Feldman: Yeah.
Oh, it wasn't title.
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm feeling very lucky.
Are you working for me?
Okay.
Good.
Then I have more ambitious, I think.
Okay.
So that color is not -- I want a red one.
And then I think, okay, this Nexus 7 is really
cool.
I actually go and list the font size for it,
and do the shift up.
Yeah, and I think, okay, so this is enough
clutter here, right?
I need to get rid of it, and go and delete
it all, and you know what, the search field,
I don't like it either.
I'll just delete it all.
>>Sam Dutton: That's too complex.
>>Pavel Feldman: Come on.
And then I think, okay, I've done a lot -- why
can't I delete it?
Come on, Google, where is it?
Yeah.
And I think, okay, that's enough, and then
I calm down, I think I like it the way it
was, and I press command C and things are
undone, or I press shift command C and things
are redone.
So we have the complete undo-redo stuck in
here that is more importantly retaining the
identity of the nodes, so when I'm deleting
nodes or recreating nodes, those are the same
objects, and your JavaScript points there
and your program remains functional with that.
So that's a cool feature.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Sam Dutton: Go back.
Go back.
Come on, while you're there, someone asked
for this, do command -- what is it, command
plus.
>>Pavel Feldman: No, I won't show you.
I'll show you the question mark.
The question mark is where you get all the
shortcuts to all the features that we have,
the ones with the shortcuts, including the
ones that go to file, go to line, and goes
to your font size.
>>Sam Dutton: Okay.
So, yeah, we've been using Chrome Canary today.
Would recommend if you're using the devtools
a lot, that you give Chrome Canary a try,
you get all the newest features and also you
can give us feedback on how you would like
to see the devtools in the future.
And if you've never filed a bug, you know,
today's the day, new.crbug.com.
Go there to file bugs, make feature requests,
anything Chrome related particularly with
the devtools, do it now, yeah, that's the
place to go for any of you stuff.
So, yeah, that's it from us, thank you very
much.
Indeed.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Sam Dutton: We've got about -- yeah, about
7 minutes for questions so if you would like
to ask questions, come up to the mics in the
aisles there.
>>> I thought of one more question, you're
taking requests for improvements to devtools.
Remote debugging is really cool, but it doesn't
work when you're offline, because it hits
app spot first.
It makes it really hard to do like mobile
development on an airplane.
>>Pavel Feldman: So I can give you advice
how to work around it, and then we'll fix
it.
So the workaround is to save that page that
is served alt app engine, and it's just a
Web app, and you save it, you open it, and
you point to your Chrome instance or your
mobile instance and it will work.
No need for a cloud there.
Okay?
>>> Is there a way to see the packets in the
Web socket?
>>Pavel Feldman: Yes, in fact you can see
the packets on the Web socket.
And let me show it to you, so that's -- okay.
I'm going to use a -- we are using those,
right, for the devtool itself, where are you
-- where are you?
Okay.
So I'll need to do devtool on devtool on devtool,
but that's probably fine.
You got used to it.
And in the network, I don't need to record.
I'll just do some stuff.
And you should see the packets in here, and
if they aren't, we just can't find them, so
the idea is that you can see the resource
responsible for the Web socket packet in here,
and in the editing part of this screen, you
will see Web socket frames tab.
I can't show it to you right now, but it's
there, and it is going to be stable in Chrome
21.
It's a recent feature.
>>Sam Dutton: And another?
>>> Hi, thank you guys for the presentation.
It was real cool.
So I have a question: Is it possible to simulate
the http request that like that made from
UI, or, you know, you click a button, you
have a bunch of requests, is it possible to
simulate a bunch of them and override some
headers, override a script that can do it.
>>Pavel Feldman: Not yet.
XHR replay simulation is very high in our
to-do list, so we are going to make it soon,
but it's not there yet.
>>Sam Dutton: Yeah, lots of people are asking
for that.
>>> Thanks.
>>> So do these techniques -- I mean the kind
of examples that you showed were a little
bit, you know, contrived obviously for the
demo, but let's say Gmail, does Gmail use
the Chrome devtools in the same way that you're
doing it or do they use different tools or
do they have different techniques in how they
use the tools, you know, for debugging and
just working with that system, because there's
literally, you know, dozens if not hundreds
of events happening per second in the timeline,
the heap snapshots will have, you know, tons
of different things, does it scale to something
at that level?
>>Pavel Feldman: Gmail is our best in-house
client so we're working with them a lot.
These three snapshot techniques with the heap
profiling was in fact -- those were discovered
while working with the Gmail team while they
were hunting their memory leaks.
They're also using timeline and, of course,
they're using RD bugger.
>>> So it does.
>>Pavel Feldman: Yes.
Of course.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>> Hi, is there a good way to inspect, edit
CSS key frames, the CSS animation key frames?
Because you can -- you can see the define
animation, but I want to see the key frames,
edit them, and then look at performance issues.
>>Pavel Feldman: So the best you can get is
just jumping to the source code and editing
them there.
Everything you do in the source code is immediately
reflected in the screen.
>>> Okay.
>>Pavel Feldman: But there is no structural
editing for the key frames and for media queries
yet.
>>> Okay.
And then is there a way to trigger them, force
them to rerun in a performance tracing kind
of context.
>>Pavel Feldman: Of course.
You can edit everything in here, and then
you just save, and then you go to the timeline
and you perform those actions and they will
be using these new styles.
Okay, thank you.
Is the mobile debugging going to be available
on Chrome for IOS?
>>Pavel Feldman: I don't know.
We'll have to check.
So the remote debugging background is a part
of WebKit, so the code is there.
I believe there is a way to remove the debugger
IOS devices.
I don't know about the Chrome, but I can find
it out for you, and e-mail that, I'll send
it back to you.
>>> Thanks.
>>> And you talked earlier about getting below
60 frames a second, there was I think green,
purple and blue were colors that you talked
about, and when you got below they all turned
gray.
What was the gray for?
>>Pavel Feldman: Okay, so here is the thing:
The frame for us is everything that beginning
of the frames, and the gray that you saw above
is the CPU activity that we do not instrument,
or it's an idle time.
We are working on distinguishing between the
two, so very soon we will be able to say this
is the CPU.
It has been doing something.
Or this is idle, the other tasks are using
it.
So we are actively working on the timeline,
on the frame mode, and it's very first revision
of it.
>>> So if it's gray and it is the CPU that's
doing it, it's your app that is causing that
CPU to spin up but you don't know why?
>>Pavel Feldman: Right, the spikes that we
saw on the timeline, the gray one, transparent
one, were related to the CPU related to the
switching in windows that I was doing as the
timeline was captured, so that was idle from
your page perspective, because it was not
wasting CPU resources, so we will be able
to cut that down soon and tell you that your
page is not responsible for it.
But the picture that we show is accurate from
the repaint perspective, from the frame perspective,
because something has been happening and your
frame has not been painted at that time, so
there was indeed a jank in the repaint.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Is there any plans on integrating a -- like
a testing framework into the devtool so, say,
macros and assertions and these kinds of things.
>>Pavel Feldman: So we have a nice extensions
API support where we add extensions for you
to be able to build your own panel in the
devtool, or to react upon selection of an
element in the elements panel and such.
We might extend those APIs if they are not
sufficient for achieving your goals.
So we -- yeah, we are -- we are relying upon
the third parties to provide the functional
like that.
>>> All right, so there's no -- right now
on that direct like roadmap, there's no plans
for a testing framework essentially?
>>Pavel Feldman: Right.
Those would be done through the extensions
at least at the first page.
>>> Okay, cool, thanks.
>>> I'm an engineer on the Google+ team, and
first of all, I just want to say thanks so
much for these tools, I couldn't do my job
without them.
I mean, they're just a real joy to use, they
make Web development fun again.
That said, we do obviously have a pretty massively
large JavaScript application and it's compiling
files together and it's starting across all
that, so at least the search across sources
made it easier again to figure out where that
JavaScript is coming from, but just loading
it in and parsing it still is pretty pokey,
it's many -- I'm just curious how optimized
that stuff is and how much you think you can
improve the performance even further when
you have really large JavaScript?
>>> All right, so, by the moment Gmail was
our like largest client, so whenever they
hit the limitation, they came to us and we
fixed it, and please, do that as well, and
we'll be improving.
So right now with the frame mode, we found
that we have a lot of junk in our own UI,
and we do know a couple of little knocks related
to the scale with our text viewer.
We are comfortable at about 100K lines.
When it goes beyond we are not that comfortable
from the memory standpoint, but those are
all fixable, so as we hit new limitations,
we are fixing them, so please provide your
feedback.
>>> Okay, great.
Will do.
Thanks.
>>Sam Dutton: Question from this side.
>>> We've been writing some code that runs
on both node.js and the client, since node.js
using V8 does it have any association with
this, or is this purely the clientside browser?
>>Pavel Feldman: Right.
This is working against the WebKit based browsers
primarily, so it does not work against V8
or node.
There is a solution that works against node,
because node supports -- exposes the V8 debugging
protocol.
There's a project called Chrome devtool for
Java that is an eclipse plug-in, and eclipse
has indicated that can connect both to Chrome
and to raw V8 including node.
I know that there is a fork of Web inspector
that works a pretty old font that works against
node, and I know there are people that are
trying to implement wrappers around V8 so
that they emulated the remote debugging protocol
that Chrome devtool is using so that we could
connect there, but that is a work in progress.
>>> Okay.
>>Pavel Feldman: So it's Chrome devtools for
Java and that is an eclipse plug-in.
>>Sam Dutton: Thanks very much.
I think we better wrap it up.
We've run out of time.
Thanks again.
Thanks also for the live feature request earlier.
We'll take note of that.
Thank you.
>>Pavel Feldman: Thank you.
[ Applause ]